[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous comme vous l'a dit jérôme
il ya quelques semaines je défendais ma
thèse de doctorat en sciences spatiales
et pour moi c'était quelque chose de
très important parce qu'en fait c'est le
premier palier dans une carrière dans la
recherche scientifique
mais quand j'ai commencé mes études la
je croyais savoir exactement ce que
c'était j'avais vraiment une idée bien
définie de ce que c'était je pensais que
j'allais intégrer un groupe même une
communauté en fait de gens qui se
dévouent totalement à la science avec un
grand s majuscule dont le seul but dans
la vie dont la seule vocation est de
mettre leur intelligence au service de
l'humanité alors évidemment c'était
qu'en partie vrai c'est vrai que j'ai
intégré une équipe qui dévouent pas mal
de son temps à la recherche mais en fait
j'avais mal compris les véritables
motivations d'un chercheur la plupart
d'entre nous n'avons pas choisi notre
carrière
par pur altruisme par envie simplement
de se mettre au service des besoins de
l'humanité
en fait ça c'est plutôt du bénéfice
collatéral ce qui pousse la plupart du
temps un chercheur dans sa voix c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus subjectif
ce n'est rien d'autre que sa propre
curiosité on fait de la recherche avant
tout essentiellement parce qu'on en a
envie
parce que ça nous intéresse parce que ça
nous rend curieux et pour la plupart
d'entre nous en fait la discipline
scientifique qu'on a choisi d'étudier
fait carrément partie de nos passions et
la carrière d'un chercheur peut prendre
une forme qui est essentiellement
déterminé par ses goûts par ses envies
parce qu'il intéresse parce qu'il a
envie d'étudier par ce qui le rend
curieux et d'ailleurs les chercheurs
peuvent plus ou moins tous se souvenir
d'un ou de plusieurs déclencheur c'est à
dire qu'en fait à un moment de sa vie
un chercheur ou un futur chercheurs
parce que la plupart du temps c'est dans
sa jeunesse un moment de sa vie un
chercheur rencontre sa discipline
scientifique un petit peu par hasard au
détour peut-être
d'un musée d'un livre d'une vidéo
pourquoi pas d'un ted
hélas hélas quelque chose se produit là
sa curiosité est éveillé et la chaîne
est amorcé et bien souvent c'est ce qui
le pousse vers sa discipline
scientifique mon déclencheur à moi je
vais pas vous le révéler tout de suite
mais je peux déjà vous dire que cette
curiosité
elle provient en fait avant tout un
véritable émerveillement et
l'émerveillement et bien souvent c'est
alimenté par par notre imagination par
notre imaginaire par leurs rêves
on dit souvent à moitié pour rire que
les scientifiques
je n'ai rien d'autre que une bande de
grands enfants en fait c'est vrai à
plusieurs niveaux je peux le confirmer
et notamment comme les enfants
les chercheurs ont une certaine capacité
à écouter leur imagination
à l'entendre à lui faire confiance et
parfois même à savoir la traduire
carrément en innovation et moi
aujourd'hui
ce que j'aimerais faire c'est vous
encourager à écouter votre imagination
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est ce que moi en fait j'ai fait toute
ma vie depuis que je suis toute petite
je sais que quand je serai grande
j'irai à l'université étudié
l'astrophysique parce que depuis cette
époque là de ma vie mon imaginaire il
est rempli de planètes d'extraterrestres
de voyage dans l'espace
et voilà où j'en suis aujourd'hui alors
mon déclencheur à moi en fait il est un
petit peu plus anodins que ce que je
vous ai cité en exemple pour moi tout a
commencé avec un film et si on voulait
être tout à fait rigoureux on devrait
dire deux trilogies puisque à mon époque
c'était déjà deux trilogies maintenant
c'est presque devenu trois trilogies
évidemment je veux parler de star wars
j'avais à peu près dix ans quand la
prélogie est sorti au cinéma puis j'ai
découvert la trilogie originale et petit
à petit j'ai commencé à aimer la science
fiction en général j'adorais ce monde
rempli d'extraterrestres invraisemblable
de voyage dans l'espace et ça m'a poussé
à me demander si ce monde de rêves et de
fiction que j'aimais tellement pouvait
exister quelque part vous pouvez exil
et en vrai et ça m'a poussé vers des
études d'astrophysique
et aujourd'hui c'est encore une de mes
passions c'est encore à mes hobbies le
fait de prendre un film de science
fiction et de s'en servir comme base à
une discussion scientifique
alors aujourd'hui on observait un film
de science fiction sur un véritable
plateau d'argent puisque le titre de cet
événement le titre de ce thé dicks il
est inspiré d'une trilogie de science
fiction qui parle du voyage dans le
temps le temps en physique en sciences
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
particulier en fait le temps on peut le
mesurer avec une montre par exemple on
peut compter les minutes restantes du
toc
mais au fond c'est quoi qu'on mesure
qu'elle est l'objet physique qu'on
mesure le temps c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment se
représenter qu'on ne peut pas toucher
qu'on ne peut pas dessiner mais on croit
savoir beaucoup de choses sur le temps
on sait qu'on peut le mesurer on sait
qu'il s'écoule inexorablement sans qu'on
puisse rien y faire qu'il s'écoule
toujours dans le même sens dans la même
direction et qu'il s'écoule toujours de
manière régulière
du moins ça c'était avant
avant l'intervention d'un monsieur
appelé albert einstein
albert einstein en fait a élargi notre
vision du temps avec cette grille de la
relativité et la théorie de la
relativité en fait elle explique que
votre temps peut s'écouler différemment
du mien notamment par exemple si vous
aller très très vite
alors pour mieux comprendre je vous
propose qu'on imagine ensemble une
petite expérience je vous propose de
monter à bord d'un train et c'est un
train un peu spécial un train super
rapide qui peut se déplacer à la vitesse
de la lumière au moins une vitesse très
très très proche de la vitesse de la
lumière peut-être 99 99%
mais avant que vous ne remarquez je
prends soin de vous confier une super
grande horloge genre horloges de gares
que vous allez s'il vous plaît tenir
bien en évidence au dessus de votre tête
et de préférence devant une fenêtre du
train parce que moi je vais rester sur
le quai et depuis ma position immobile
je vais observer votre passage à la
vitesse de la lumière et je vais faire
ça tout en gardant un oeil sur ma montre
personnel vous monter dans le train vous
prenez votre horloge le train démarre à
ce moment là
bien que vous et moi semblions toujours
ressentir les mêmes secondes
nous ressentons toujours le même
écoulement du temps individuellement et
bien moi depuis ma position de mobiles
sur le quai quand je regarde votre
horloge passer rapidement
je constate que les secondes s'égrènent
plus lentement pour vous vos secondes
avoue sont plus longues la trotteuse de
votre horloge va plus lentement que
celle de ma montre du fait que vous vous
déplacez à la vitesse de la lumière le
temps pour vous s'est dilaté
c'est donc ce qu'on appelle la
dilatation relativiste du temps alors
évidemment c'est bien entendu une
expérience de pensée
il n'existe à ma connaissance aucun
train capable de se déplacer à la
vitesse de la lumière qui est à peu près
300 mille kilomètres par seconde
mais dans la science fiction et en
particulier dans mon très cher star wars
les protagonistes dispose deux vaisseaux
spatiaux capables de se déplacer à la
vitesse de la lumière il devrait donc
ressentir les effets de la relativité
c'est à dire que quand les passagers du
faucon millenium voyage une heure par
exemple
à la vitesse de la lumière les habitants
de la galaxie rester bien sagement sur
leur planète
immobile pour eux il s'écoule peut-être
des semaines des mois et ce serait donc
assez peu commode au niveau du scénario
imaginons par exemple la scène où luke
skywalker décide de quitter
précipitamment son entraînement de jedi
parce qu'il a ressenti que ses amis
étaient en danger sur une planète
lointaine bien même avec le vaisseau
spatial le plus rapide de la galaxie
cette entreprise est complètement voué à
l'échec puisque à cause de la dilatation
temporelle à son arrivée tout le monde
sera probablement déjà mort mais bien
sûr soyons indulgents on demande pas à
un film de science fiction de respecter
les lois de la physique
on lui demande d'avoir un scénario
cohérent mais cependant il existe
un film de science fiction au moins un
en tout cas à ma connaissance qui est
parvenu à mettre en scène la dilatation
relativiste du temps d'une manière à la
fois scientifiquement correcte et
artistiquement pertinente belle et
politique
c'est un film de 2014 je veux parler d'
interstellar dans interstellar deux
astronautes voyage sur une planète
imaginaire
baptisé la planète millaire et la
planète muller a ceci de particulier
qu'elle vit autour d'un trou noir et ce
voyage à un terrible coup pour nos deux
astronautes puisqu'il souffre d'une
grosse dilatation du temps c'est à dire
que une heure passée sur la planète
millaire équivaut à 7 ans pour leurs
familles restées sur terre c'est donc un
élément important du déroulement de
l'histoire cette dilatation relativiste
du temps alors cette fois ci les
astronautes ressentent une telle
dilatation du temps n'ont pas tellement
à cause de la grande vitesse à laquelle
ils ont voyagé jusqu'à la planète
millaire mais plutôt du fait que la
planète millaire et en orbite autour
d'un trou noir
un trou noir en fait c'est simplement
une région de l'espace où une masse
infiniment dense et compacte à creuser
autour d'elle un pouilly
gravitationnelle infinie dont rien ne
peut s'échapper
pas même la lumière d'où d'ailleurs le
nom de trous noirs et cette attraction
gravitationnelle infinie que le trou
noir exerce sur son voisinage est
capable d'y ralentir également
l'écoulement du temps c'est encore un
effet relativiste et c'est cet effet qui
a été assez correctement mis en scène
dans le film interstellar une chose
intéressante à noter c'est que le film
interstellar a été réalisé en
collaboration avec de vrais
astrophysicien et il a même donné lieu à
des publications scientifiques tout à
fait légitime
c'est donc dire si l'imaginaire peut
parfois alimentés l'innovation donc pour
résumer votre temps peut s'écouler
différemment du mien si vous aller très
très vite
ou si vous vivez dans un champ
gravitationnel beaucoup plus fort que
moi
et même si ces deux effets
paraître très très science fiction en
réalité la dilatation relativise du
temps ça s'observe ça existe j'oserais
même dire que ça affecte notre quotidien
notamment au travers d'un petit objet de
technologies dont je suis prête à parier
qu'au moins la moitié d'entre vous s'en
est servi aujourd'hui je veux parler du
gps alors le gps en fait comment ça
marche bien le récepteur gps qu'on a sur
terre et la plupart du temps c'est dans
nos voitures communique en permanence
avec une constellation de satellites il
y en a environ une trentaine qui vivent
donc en orbite autour de la terre et ses
satellites à leur bord ils ont chacun
une horloge extrêmement précise et il
envoie des signaux en continu vers la
terre avec entre autres comme
information leur à leur bord grâce en
fait à cette information temporel à
cette information sur l'heure à bord du
satellite
le récepteur gps dont on dispose sur
terre est capable d'estimer sa position
par rapport à une poignée de ce
satellite et par extension sa position
sur terre ok facile ces satellites
ils vivent dans l'espace ils subissent
donc une gravité différente de moi avec
mon récepteur gps dans la voiture c'est
donc le même effet qu'il ya dans
interstellar mais à l'envers en fait
puisque leur gravité plus faibles et
puisqu'ils vivent sur une orbite autour
de la terre
il tourne donc autour de la terre avec
une certaine vitesse et en l'occurrence
la vitesse des satellites gps
c'est à peu près trois kilomètres par
seconde alors c'est pas encore la
vitesse de la lumière qui était de 300
mille kilomètres par seconde à peu près
mais c'est déjà suffisant pour avoir une
petite dilatation du temps et quand on
combine les deux effets relativistes
ressentie par les satellites gps on se
rend compte en fait que chaque jour
chaque 24 heures
les horloges à leur bord accuse une
erreur d'à peu près 30 8 microsecondes
ça veut dire que tous les jours il faut
corriger les horloges des satellites gps
est à peu près 30 8 microsecondes 38
micro secondes sur une journée ça peut
paraître absolument dérisoire mais dans
les calculs
deux positions de nos récepteurs gps ça
peut se traduire en erreur de presque 10
km ce qui est donc assez peu négligeable
notamment quand on recherche un bâtiment
en pleine ville de liège
on peut donc remercier très
chaleureusement notre ami einstein pour
avoir mis en mathématiques la relativité
la dilatation du temps et pour garantir
le bon fonctionnement de nos gps et
d'ailleurs pour en revenir à albert
einstein
en fait moi je pense que s'il est
parvenu à mettre sur pied la théorie de
la relativité
c'est probablement pas en se levant à
matin et en se disant aujourd'hui
l'humanité a grand besoin d'une bonne
compréhension scientifique du temps
alors aujourd'hui je maintiens mon
bureau je me retrousse les manches j'y
vais au finish je dors pas je mange pas
tant que j'ai pas terminée cette bonne
définition physique du temps en fait à
l'époque au début des années 1900 à
l'époque ou einstein a publié cette
théorie en fait einstein était employé
dans un bureau de brevets et à son
époque il voyait passer énormément de
brevets pour des horloges mécaniques
toujours de plus en plus précises et moi
je suis prête à parier que c'est en
voyant passer tous ses brevets pour des
horloges que sa curiosité pour
l'écoulement du temps a été éveillée
en fait moi je pense que le génie
d'albert einstein réside surtout dans le
fait de s'être laissé émerveillés par
quelque chose d'aussi simple que
l'écoulement du temps un petit peu
peut-être comme isaac newton c'est
laisser émerveiller par les pommes qui
tombe et moi en l'occurrence
et bien moi je suis émerveillé par les
films de science fiction
parce que si dans la réalité les lois
physiques limite ce qu'on peut faire
limite ce avec quoi on peut expérimenter
dans la science fiction les seules
limites sont celles de l'imagination
on peut donc virtuellement tout essayé
pousser les lois physiques dans leurs
derniers retranchements et c'est un
véritable terrain de jeu pour
l'innovation est d'ailleurs ce qui est
magnifique c'est que parfois la réalité
finit par rattraper la science fiction
par exemple
plusieurs dizaines d'années avant à la
popularisation des téléphones portables
le capitaine kirk en utilisait déjà un
avant tout le monde
dans star trek ou plus fort encore à son
époque
jules verne écrivait déjà le premier
voyage de l'homme sur la lune
pratiquement 100 ans avant que ça ne se
produise en vrai ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que la science fiction du passé
est devenu en partie la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est donc ça veut dire que
la science fiction d'aujourd'hui la
science fiction contemporaine
peut-être prédit-elle en partie notre
futur la réalité de notre futur est
d'ailleurs les sujets qui sont à la mode
dans les oeuvres de science fiction
contemporaine eh bien ce sont des sujets
qui existent également dans les
laboratoires et dans les instituts de
recherche comme par exemple
l'exploration martienne avec le film
seul sur mars où la réalité virtuelle la
médecine personnalisée est connecté ou
comme dominique ohl a montré tout à
l'heure la présidence de donald trump
l'imaginaire d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'innovation de demain et c'est pour ça
que moi j'aimerais vous encourager à
écouter votre imagination vous verrez
que ça va aiguiser votre curiosité et
que ça vous permettra peut-être d'offrir
à votre esprit d'innovation un terrain
de jeu par exemple la prochaine fois que
vous regardez un film de science fiction
demandez vous à quel point ce que vous y
voyez peut un jour devenir notre réalité
si on prend l'exemple de retour vers le
futur et du voyage dans le temps
aujourd'hui désolé
le voyage dans le temps relève encore de
la science fiction plutôt que de la
science mais ces deux disciplines se
croisent et il est permis d'espérer
et qui sait où la curiosité scientifique
pourra nous mener d'ici quelques années
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]